so the kingdom of tomania is in the
red mom and papa to men are in a panic
their only asset is their son and heir
indulgent in hock and most of the time in bed
count bosco the royal wakerupper has been sent
to awaken the prince and given the bad news
that he has been betrothed to the
wealthy princess mona of bologna
the prince he has an off-the-face
face and it's wide open
the morning eye-opener is the prince's favorite
a double malted eggola cola zamboa with ice cream
mama and papa still at it
and there he is the beau drummo of the
palace an hourglass figure for an egghead
careful of that cigarette princey
now she goes down the hatch
better get rid of that butt ready aim ten to
one he flips it straight the other way fire
fire is right he should have looked where he was
throwing instead of throwing where he was looking
the other way bosco ah here comes the bride
princess mona the royal bag of bologna
mona's maid not bad some dish hey
prince that's for me says the wolf
the ddt squad all set for the kill
the prince tries a new perfume violent
passion
just to pick up girl the kiss and
mama likes a mustache wearing a man
that violent perfume is working pass the aspirin
a real love the baron borax he wants
no part of mona the big bologna
the king says you've got to get us out of
huck your to the country to the flag to yale
okay [ __ ] for yale farewell bachelor dinner the
table is loaded with sweets ah the society editor
the poor bozo was carrying a torch for the maid
oh oh the prince is on a diet no
more sweets and there go the sweets
prologue to a duel
wine dying and right in the kisser
the prince is forced to face the issue
and the dough at last
the prince comes clean
uh watch that chair
there's dirty work a foot
ah he's going to get clubby
and the club going to meet a new member
whoops we won't go into that ah my trusty sword
back in the uh my trusty sword back turn it around
that's better now he'll go in and tell
him he's stuck the baron for drinks
didn't i tell you careful little
liar isn't he a message from garcia
the lady goes to work
another court member
he goes for the big cheese he didn't
learn that step it off in murray's
she's giving him the old business
so is the mouse the same
situation could happen with ants
he's got a lady in the balcony doctor
so long sam
here comes our hero now
watch out she's up to no good
just an old keyhole hound
uh don't go in you'll be sorry the landlord duck
alone at last at last alone alone at
last i think i'll sit this one out
clever is he a man or mouse is something rotten
in the state of tomania that's it kilroy is here
well look who's here mother
warned him about girls like that
stop that you
she wants him to release the baron who want a
display of emotion what acting what facility
curtain call
i beg your pardon i spoke too fast
this was worth fighting for
he's in there playing house open the door richard
this is called the bums rush
a convention
life can be so difficult i
wouldn't call this a bed of roses
watch that lift restless little kitten isn't she
contact and so to bedlam
the plot thickens
they're off the prince leads by two lengths
right in the home stretch their home
the poor fish is hooked love finds a way
my son my son wants a squirt always a squirt
here's a new twist folks this
picture ends with love at first fight